[Musique]
jusqu'à 9 heures good morning business
et à 8h17 dit chevrillon reçoit bruno
retailleau le patron des républicains au
sénat
bruno retailleau bonjour bonjour aux
échelons merci d'être là beaucoup de
questions à voir avec vous parce que
vous aimez beaucoup l'économie on veut
en profiter
il ya évidemment la réforme des
retraites vous prenez toujours départ à
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans on va
revenir sur les quotas d'immigration
professionnelle mais d'avoir une petite
question quand même sur le retour des
privatisations puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est
le top départ de la après la
privatisation de la française des jeux
de la fdj est ce que vous dites une
bonne opportunité ce que c'est
l'occasion c'est bien de ne revenir si
on peut faire un actionnariat populaire
l'actionnariat populaire bien sûr et moi
je suis favorable aux privatisations
celle ci a pas grand sens privatiser un
monopole n'a pas beaucoup de sens créé
beaucoup de sens par exemple c'est que
l'état quitte le capital d'orange de
france télécom voilà ça ce sont des
vrais privatisations prévues à titien
monopole n'a pas vraiment de sens au
niveau économique maintenant pour les
petits porteurs c'est évidemment une
opportunité je regrette aussi que cet
argent serve très très très très peu
finalement au désendettement de la
france voilà c'est arrivé
justement c'est fait au contraire pour
porter à fond qui doit investir
vous qui aimez taxe c'est un prétexte
vous savez ce fonds sera de moins de 400
millions d'euros
quand j'étais prison de région j'ai
lancé sur sur trois années un fonds pour
l'industrie du futur pour mes pme y en a
plusieurs centaines qui va en bénéficier
il était de près de 300 millions d'euros
dont vous vous rendez compte 300
millions d'euros au niveau de l'état
c'est rien c'est ça ne permet de rien
faire juste une petite question là
dessus puisque vous vous connaissez très
bien la question du numérique vous avez
suivi ça depuis longtemps
il a justement vous vous penchez sur la
souveraineté numérique en même temps
vous dites il faut privatiser orange
c'est un peu contradictoire parce que
dans rangé à la 5g il ya éventuellement
la question de la souveraineté numérique
non pas du tout ma fille l'attisé vous
sortir vous avez raison mais non c'est
très très différent moi je pense que
l'ère numérique aujourd'hui vous savez
que internet et aînés comme une promesse
libérale libertaire
or les stratégies de puissance des états
désormais se déploie dans l'espace
numérique est ce que moi je préconise
c'est une question de la souveraineté
numérique c'est par exemple sur les
données je suis favorable comme gaspard
koenig à la patrimonialisation des
données par personnel je pense qu'il
faut un cloud public
je pense qu'il faut une
de régulation de l'ia on n'ira jamais
jusqu'au code source mais on peut comme
la dgccrf pour un somme de produits voir
les conséquences de l'est à voir sa
loyauté sa transparence
on peut aussi faire comme les
britanniques qui ont que crée la 77e
brigade pour lutter contre la
cybercriminalité et notamment sur les
attaques contre la démocratie
il ya plein de choses à faire et il faut
le faire la france et aussi avec
d'autres partenaires européens ont pas
l'immigration de quotas d'immigration
professionnelle avec édouard filet canon
présenter son plan en disant qu'il veut
reprendre le contrôle de l'immigration
nous va rester sur le côté à le quota
immigration professionnelle
les français ils sont assez favorables
et tient à peu près six sur dix qui dit
c'est plutôt une bonne idée
vous vous êtes a priori opposées
pourquoi je suis pas opposé pendant les
présidentielles
nous avions à l'époque nous avions
proposé en fait des plafonds des
plafonds pour les métiers pour la
professionnelle mais aussi par exemple
pour le regroupement familial mais
c'était ça n'était pas des quotas
d'ouverture c'était des plafonds qu'il y
ait un certain nombre de traits diplômés
qui souhaitent entrer en france parce
que on a nous des besoins bien sûr mais
je vous ferai remarquer que le taux de
chômage des étrangers en france il est
le double des nationaux quand on est un
pays de chômage de masse il faut d'abord
former nos nationaux pour qu'ils
accèdent
mais au terme mais bien sûr enfin vous
êtes vous savez bien qu'il ya un plan
formation 13 le pic a été qui a été mise
en place le pic comme vous dites en face
de ce temps je voulais éviter mais la
question c'est que ça prend du temps
donc en attendant on a besoin c'est vrai
qu'il ya des des filières où il ya un
manque de compétences mais ça ne marche
pas parce que les immigrés qui viennent
sur notre sol en réalité ce sont souvent
ceux qui crèvent la faim qui sont pas du
tout dans leur pays vous avez signé pas
de la mauvaise politique parce que vous
avez bien dit mais l'insu du lanot me
laissera bien mixé par branches région
par région et à partir de là on fixera
les que par exemple que ce soit par
exemple des ingénieurs des
informaticiens indiens bien sûr que j'y
vois aucun inconvénient
mais vous verrez ce sera marginal parce
que le flux ce sont des gens qui ne sont
qui ne sont pas formés voilà et
attention par ailleurs à ne pas aspirer
les compétences des pays en voie de
développement qui
aussi en ont besoin ce que je veux
simplement dire je vais me contenter de
parler au niveau des quotas
professionnels l'objectif de voir
philippe c'est de reprendre le contrôle
permettez moi de vous dire que dans un
an vous et moi nous constaterons que la
reprise du contrôle de l'immigration
massive en france n'a pas du tout été
reprise c'est pour moi une évidence
pourquoi
pour trois raisons d'abord on ne fait
rien sur le regroupement familial la
suède l'allemagne l'ont fait une fin et
on a fait l'inversé
on a ouvert avec la loi de gérard
collomb dit diana deuxième chose sur le
droit d'asile
on ne fait rien de plus de ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne et beaucoup d'autres pays et
l'immigration pour les soins la m dans
quelques semaines le sénat proposera à
nouveau de transformer les émeut en aide
médicale d'urgence le gouvernement
refusera donc tous qu'on ne traite pas
les causes et bien donc on aura
l'immigration massive
le fait d'ouvrir via des quotas
d'immigration professionnelle vous
pensez que c'est une fausse piste en
fait je connais je pense que c'est un
faux nez exact je pense que c'est le
miroir aux alouettes
je pense que ces miroirs aux alouettes
qui cache en réalité une logique de
fausses fermeté voilà c'est c'est eh ben
si lon d'abord les migrations
professionnelles c'est 12% et
malheureusement se sont pas sentis très
près sur des tables seulement sur deux
cent cinquante cinq mille titres de
séjour accordées pour 2018 mais
malheureusement ceux qui veulent venir
en france ce sont des non diplômés
malheureusement l'autre grand sujet
évidemment c'est la réforme des
retraites est ce que vous redoutez cette
journée du 5 décembre convoi brandi un
peu comme un totem peut-être à tort
ajustement est est ce que vous vous
sentez la colère qui gronde mais sur
cinq d'essence et demain mais dès
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés à prendre le train c'est
incroyable la france est à nouveau prise
en otage c'est scandaleux
voilà donc la réforme des retraites le
problème est qu'elle est profondément
anxiogène parce qu'on en parle depuis
deux ans et on sait plus on en est
puisque maintenant on ne peut pas faire
ça d'un claquement droit mais je vois ça
ça engage sur le long terme
c'est un langage sans doute sur le long
terme mais un moment donné bien sûr quel
temps de la concertation
ça fait deux ans que jean paul delevoye
concert il faut désormais dire où on va
mails macron souffle le chaud et le
froid
la dernière trouvaille c'était la
fameuse clause grand père voilà qui
repousserait à garoua à 2068 mais le
patron c'est pas jean paul delevoye
aider simplement commissaire pour les
retraites c'est monsieur macron donc que
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une tension parce que la politique est
mal macron sur les retraites et les
tongs sujet qu'est ce qu'une bonne
réforme en réalité une bonne réforme qui
avait conduit françois fillon vous avez
la même ampleur quand même maintenant
parce que la tournée ça révolue ma
famille politique dieu sait si je suis
pas le dernier à critiquer lorsque on a
été trop peu courageux mais très
franchement entre la réforme de 93 celle
de 2003 2004 et celle de 2010 c'est à
chaque fois la droite ici en france qui
a pris des mesures courageuses notamment
pour reculer l'âge de départ
et là la question est la même monsieur
macron monsieur le bâtonnier du niveau
64 ans ont tournoyé on tourne autour
il faut assumer pourquoi est ce que le
pouvoir a fait le choix d'appauvrir les
retraités la csg la désindexation c'est
parce que il y avait un engagement du
président de la république lorsqu'il
était candidat de ne pas toucher à l'âge
légal de départ de 62 ans
eh bien il n'y a pas de choix quand vous
ne touchez pas à l'âge de départ
eh bien vous diminuer les pensions c'est
ce que les français sentent avec
beaucoup d'injustices 1 les régimes
spéciaux
ça n'est plus possible mais donc cessé
mais c'est ce que veut faire cette
retraite oui mais j'attends réforme des
retraites ça dépasse vous lui dites faut
aller plus vite et il faut il virer il
faut y arriver il faut réserver le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités
par conséquent dans un premier temps 64
ans mais très vite 65 ans on n'y coupera
pas il faut dire aux français que quand
mitterrand a fait cette réforme 65 ans à
60 ans l'espérance de vie était de 74
ans aujourd'hui elle est de 83 ans
faut pas avoir fait les grandes écoles
pour voir qu'avec la baisse de la
démographie et des natalité en france on
va avoir un souci on peut dire ça aussi
à la droite un siège permanent au noyau
même et en même temps on voit bien
regarder les français sont opposés à
sable on voit ce moment-là vous remettez
dans la rue et du reste c'est peut-être
son exposé les français mais au fait de
décaler le départ là mais il faut leur
dire il faut leur dire moi je pense que
les français l'ont beaucoup de bon sens
si vous dites vous français écoutent et
y'a pas d'autre choix puisque nos
entreprises subissent des prélèvements
les plus lourds d'europe
donc on va pas augmenter les cotisations
c'est une évidence donc le choix qu'on a
c'est un départ repoussé 64 65 ans et en
maintien justement le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités et les lions ont vraiment
les petites retraites c'est français
n'attend pas plus la question de la
pénibilité et la question des carrières
longues mais bien sûr c'est un exercice
compliqué de chevreuils ont repoussé
d'un an le départ
l'âge légal c'est 10 milliards
d'économies et bien quand on fait 10
milliards d'économies ça nous permet
d'en redistribuer une partie pour
augmenter les petites retraites et pour
tenir compte des longues carrières et
longue carrière vous souvenez c'est la
droite qui l'a fait ce dispositif
donc moi je pense que les français l'ont
beaucoup de bon sens et il faut mettre
sur la table les vrais choix comme en
plus on est en train de détricoter
depuis françois hollande
la politique familiale on va le faire
aussi par le sénat nous voterons pas ya
à nouveau une mesure de détricotage la
politique familiale qu'est ce qui se
passe depuis trois ans et bien
malheureusement les naissances chute
les décès augmente en france c'est à
dire que un régime de répartition
c'est un équilibre entre les actifs
entre la natalité et puis les les plus
âgés et aujourd'hui on est en train de
casser à nouveau cet équilibre parce
qu'on a plus de politique familiale
en france cela dit bruno retailleau
c'est une réforme des retraites est ce
que vous vous allez est ce que c'est le
président du groupe l aréna est ce que
vous allez voter ou est-ce que le groupe
à l'assemblée nationale va soutenir
cette réforme d'étape de retraite je
leur avais quand vous aurez à projet de
loi je la soutiendrai un si elle
garantit le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
2 si elle est juste c'est à dire plus de
régimes spéciaux juste aussi pour les
femmes aujourd'hui monsieur delvoye
prévoit que pour la pension de
reversions pour les veuves on recule de
7 ans on passe de 55 à 60 ans prévoit il
prévoit aussi que les femmes perdent un
certain davantage par exemple les huit
trimestres
or vous savez qu'une femme a à peu près
40% de moins de niveau de retraite parce
que son parcours professionnel a été
heurtée donc
6 1 on a le pouvoir d'achat garanti pour
les retraités
2 si elle est juste et 6 3 elle est
robuste c'est à dire que l et finança
parce que dès cette année on est dans le
rouge
qu'est-ce que mêmes macron edward fils
vont faire avant 2022 pour équilibrer
les comptes qui ne sont plus l équilibre
il va appliquer la loi touraine merci
merci beaucoup bruno retailleau donkova
quand même peut être une ouverture en
tous les cas sur le vote de la réforme
des retraites
merci beaucoup d'avoir effectué bruno
retailleau le président du groupe plr au
sénat était notre invité cet amour
christain mercier lige on vous retrouve
à midi et puis ce soir pour la cérémonie
des bfm awards tout de suite le jeune de
l'économie avec faïza guène younsi